spetta a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono farisei oggi
siamo tornati su sixties ecco che hanno
aggiornato ringraziando il gesù in terra
perché hanno aggiunto in primis la
lingua in italiano grazie di dio non
devo più sciogliermi gli occhi per
tradurre oltre ad aver raggiunto appunto
la lingua italiana ragazze hanno
cambiato anche un sacco di roba è quindi
dobbiamo dobbiamo farci ok abbiamo venti
secondi che sto comunque pochi tesoro
nostro figlio appena scassato un vaso
devo fare qua aiuto aiuto
questo che non so che cos'è la mappa
della mappa la bottiglia riviste porno
perfetto messaggio sto facendo pagare lo
so io l'ho anche prendere i miei figli
giusto mi chiami ricordo più come si
gioca ragazzo questo problema di fondo
che mi che ha cambiato botto effetto
togliti figlio del cazzo mica quanta
roba c'è qua non ho preso una sega
porcaccia [ __ ] dove mia mia moglie
riprendo tesoro vieni niente non ce l'ho
fatta sono tutto scarso porca eva non
sono capace ragazzi alla mia iniziale
gravano già dentro
ragazzi miei è stato difficilissimo
riuscire a raccogliere tutto ma ce l'ho
fatta perché non c'è mia figlia avere
tanto la figlia era inutile va bene così
di va avanti ragazzi allora primo giorno
siamo riusciti ad entrare quasi tutti
nel rifugio quasi adesso dobbiamo
inventarci modi creativi per servire la
zuppa in scatola ci pensa lo chef fabio
poi sono più i barattoli ma agiremo
barattoli dormiremo sui barattoli ci
parleremo anche con i barattoli anzi
alcuni di noi già lo fanno un abbondante
scocchera corato storia elettro e
andiamo avanti dai razioniamo le
provviste non mangiate e bevete un cazzo
perché il primo giorno a che che orgasmo
leggere l'italiano non devo tradurmi una
sega e bellissimo sembra che la zona sia
ancora irradiata uscire in questo mente
pericolosa meno che qualcuno non abbia
voglia di ammalarsi e quindi io non
dovevo mandare tutti quanti fuori
all'inizio e che cazzo ne so ditemelo
primati mi può far massima tante mio
figlio chi se ne sbatte ma nel mio
figlio vai vai vai qualcuno sta bussando
polisti senza la botola abbiamo paura di
aprire ma potrebbe essere una buona
notizia ai apriamo apriamo
io apro perché sono tutto buono babbo
natale eri tu era mia figlia è rimasta
fuori un giorno a caso poteva entrare
benissimo quel che ci aspettavamo erano
guai grandi o piccoli ma guai non
immaginavamo di trovare mary jane dietro
la porta
effettivamente era meglio se non entrava
ha detto di essere sopravvissuto
all'esplosione infilandosi nel frigo
geniale se a face rogue a scuola se ne
magna dal frigo ora come sta messa mary
jane è uscita di seno mary jane e molto
stanca non sarebbero racket imi benesse
a una brutta cera d'acqua non
sopravvivere senza bere ma oggi nessuno
beve vela piate intercooler domani
bevete dovevo scegliere chi lo è più
qualità di affrontare la landa desolata
tim yip vai a [ __ ] che bisogna
tornare neanche da bere brutto bambino
ho perso un figlio ma ho guadagnato una
fibbia fantastico c'è ancora nell'acqua
a mary jane non fa altro che chiede a
non poter aprire la foto che bere
qualcosa facciamo così scorta di acqua
per tutti sono buono oggi è terribile
non riusciamo a dormire non è un
problema mio ha infilato il fucile
nell'ano bene mi piace questo gioco in
italiano è bellissimo perché mia figlia
sta così chi cazzo stai aspettando il
principe azzurro a te lo sai magnato
pure quello ragazzi siamo a 6 giorni
nessuno ancora mangiato niente fate voi
non avete fame in un video da mangiare
cazzi vostri
di certo non si aspetta che una banda di
persone vestite di verde si presenti
alla porti chiarendo di prendere i
ricchi per donare ai poveri invece è
successo a noi li dobbiamo fare entrare
questi pagliacci forse ci faranno
divertire un po che no perché noi siamo
messi abbastanza bene con la roma quindi
stukas bene così ed è tornato veramente
se per caso hai trovato solo una
bottiglia esci fuori immediatamente
proprio di ricorrere una zuppa hai
trovato una zuppa cazzo hai passato
tutto suo tempo nella sala giochi spiega
mi sono anche la pagina dopo la mia fan
culo
ok sportiva 2 2 bottiglie o bene una
radio
se hai trovato anche una playstation
siamo a posto sky uno per ogni tanto
devo dire che la facciamo così oggi
razione d'acqua e di cibo per tutti
quanti perché la sete meritata se veniva
nei saluti in questo bunker minuscolo
vai accenni a radio che vediamo se ci
chiamano i militari cosa che anche se
succede non serve un caso
vabbè giorno 8 non mangiavo nessuno
fuori tanto ancora tutto radioattivo
buone notizie il governo annunciato
radio che evaporano i sopravvissuti alla
nostra zona non aspettare un altro po lo
è ok ferite di mary jane sono messe
molto male
fini vorrebbe mangiare qualcosa dove
resa riposato ed sta bene bene io
pensavo che mandare fuori dalla gente al
giorno 40 o giorno 4 fosse la stessa
cosa invece no cazzo ma vi che lo
stamattina qualcosa ci stava osservando
da un angolo del rifugio pensiamo si
tratti di un topo qualcosa di simile
sembrava anche ben nutrito dobbiamo
sbarazzarci non sarà quella cosa
sbarazzarsi di noi
vai col fucile zio in bocca sparagli
quel bastardo
se non era una visione ragazzi non era
vero qualunque cosa fosse ora è morta
decisamente morta forse ce ne sono altri
ascoltiamo che partì in quei buchi nel
rifugio ma che cazzo di bunker è una
groviera piani buchi ci ha scioccato
mentre la sola e mary jane ha iniziato a
mettere mano sulle nostre provviste di
cibo però non ha mangiato né bevuto
niente semplicemente gettato tutto nel
limbo di tutto ammazzo dame dove c'è
ancora proiettili del fucile io ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo tutti devono bere
unità che cazzo hai buttato una zuppa
portava già chi lo dice a giovanni rana
adesso a magnate al frigo o brutta
stronzate digiuno stai non mangi non è
tempo di pensare alle domande vai vai
generale nessuno mangia qua la prossima
volta mangiate tranne mary jane quando
mangia ordinati un kebab la ricaduta
radioattiva è quasi terminata dovrebbe
essere più sicuro viaggiare in
superficie se mary jane viene in
continuazione
meno male perché se non veniva da sola
la facevo svenire io a furia di testate
sul naso e bassa dell'acqua in teoria
dell'acqua tutti senza cibo tanto a mary
jane non darei comunque del cibo perché
una [ __ ]
per fortuna oggi non accaduto nulla di
nuovo a mary jane che peccato guarda
bravo schiantasse ma non volevamo di
certo che le cascate del niagara
venissero da noi ora sembra però che una
mezza dozzina di tubi si è esplosa a
come dobbiamo salvare le nostre
provviste cazzo non posso scegliere una
mappa o la radio la radio da porca eva
lercia leciti in quattro non potevano
tenerla radio e l'altro tenere la mappa
deficienti la radio è stata salvata
prima che quel liquido il mondo la
danneggiasse lei gen continua a
comportarsi modo strano non è più la
ragazza allegra solare di una volta mi
chiamo ieri testate sono mangia perché
non siete riusciti a salvare una cazzo
di mappa dei deficienti mary jane
vorrebbe mangiare qualcosa c'è ancora
dell'acqua mary jane non fa altro che
chiedono
vuole l'acqua adesso ha fame meriggio in
poverino mary jane cafà gli darei la
maschera antigas da mangiare brutta
[ __ ] medigene piuttosto affamata mary
jane in peace viene in continuazione
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa da bere subito
quando ti ami è tornato alla spedizione
sembrava star bene poi però abbiamo
scoperto che si era ferito a una mano
con del ferro mia vita infetta non
sembra che stia guarendo dobbiamo
medicarla porca [ __ ] non c'è ne uno
nell'altro zio non possiamo tagliarsi il
braccio mi spiace oa cazzo perdo tutti i
due figli vabbè sticazzi gli occhi muore
prima faceva gara nei geni piuttosto
affamata non sto ancora morendo mary
jane incredibile drin drin credevamo non
avremo più sentito il dolce sono di un
telefono con la riprevisione apparecchio
iniziato a squillare all'esterno sarà
stata la cabina sulla strada forse
bisognerebbe rispondere corri donna
corre chi era al telefono era la norma
che chiedeva se aveva mangiato sicura
cosa mi ha risposto al telefono che ho
sentito chiaramente un sospiro di
sollievo si trattava di sopravvissuti
della città vicina di hill valley aveva
iniziato a scriverci formazioni up è
caduta la linea
qui non prendi non prendi e un cazzo non
prende qualcosa deve essere andato
storto da loro avevano la moda è stato
veloce del dolore stornare sana e salva
almeno il pene non lo infili in un
divano sono mary jane si è presa
qualcosa di brutto si è preso due
schiaffi ecco che sorpresa la zia non mi
porta dell'acqua siamo nella merda ma
nella merda forte sia dei portali
dell'acqua subito ricorrere giorno 20
forza la radio capita qualcosa cosa
succede mary jane oggi non ha dato
problemi
o forse i problemi non hanno avuto il
coraggio di darle noia chi è che scrive
ste robe spiega minchia ragazzo al 91 ce
la potremo fare
cos'è dove cazzo è mio figlio mi era
molto malato non potevamo aiutarlo forse
se n'è reso conto e ha pensato che fosse
meglio tenersi alla larga da dei
genitori così irresponsabili se ne è
tornato non è più tornato non potevi
andare via tu che sei una [ __ ]
mi dispiace figlio va bene arrivata una
donna con una strana creatura era suo
marito senza la carta di credito quel
dice che è un cammello ma a cinque zampe
è perché è la quinta non è una zampa
comunque l'animale trasporta della merce
da barattare offre una bottiglia in
cambio di della dama quattro bottiglie
in cambio di una radio
allora facciamo così io prego iddio che
mary jane dintorni con
io non lo so se barattarla radio a
quattro bottiglie soltanto quattro
bottiglie dai me ne frega un cazzo
tornerà qua radio mary jane me lo sento
me lo sento che porta una radio non lo
sento va emergendo una volta concluso lo
scambio quella donna andata via per la
sua strada prima di andarsene si è
raccomandata di ascoltare la radio ma sa
glielo appena data service mariah era
presa per il culo sempre se vogliamo
andarci una questo rifugio e trovare un
posto sicuro tutti devono però ogni
tanto anche mary jane ce ne corre
dell'acqua mary jane è uscita di seno di
nuovo non ha niente bene i ragazzi
niente bene
porca [ __ ] speriamo che torni con la
radio con la tipa speriamo che torni
soprattutto maniera non è neanche detto
che torni eravamo certi che veri geni
avesse compiuto gli anni due settimane
fa abbiamo scoperto che invece oggi
questa potrebbe piacere una ragazza
intrappolata in un rifugio lacca per
capelli che non è assolutamente quello
oppure un kit nessuno di questi perché
non ho un cazzo mi dispiace figlia altro
che rick ansa qua c'è una sega per il
compleanno a coppia di sconosciuti
palmenti banditi rovistava tra le
macerie della nostra casa abbiamo ridato
la loro conversazione una parla uno
parlava di una donna che avevano
catturato dalla descrizione sembrava
dolores arca [ __ ] porca nel gene troppo
grande per i compleanni ecco come la
vediamo
poverina cori ted corri forte ed ce la
devi fare come cazzo è che l'unica che
non c'era erano partiti senza è tornata
ha fatto un casino perché ha buttato via
le scorte di cibo ed è rimasta pure
l'unica invita alla l'unica che volevo
morta non so come sia possibile
incredibili le ferite di mary jane e
avevano pretesa scontrosa forse perché
non abbiamo fatto nulla per curarle non
avevo niente
stamattina appena svegliati abbiamo
trovato un suo biglietto in cui dice che
merita di meglio che se ne andrà in
canada
visto che hanno un sistema sanitario
migliore sopravvissuti per 30 giorni
chi è chi è che ha letto il biglietto
che non c'era più nessuno in casa che
cazzola letto sto biglietto spiegatemi
siete stati cacciati via ruspa
ragazzi miei spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che siate più contenti di mary
jane che era scontento è andata in
canada
se non per caso sapete che il canada e
la risposta altro consiglio non
barattate mai una radio con quattro
bottiglie perché tanto non serve un
cazzo spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato
alquanto strano riuscire a giocare alla
roma e perdere miseramente ma vabbè
quindi ragazzi miei spero che video vi
sia piaciuto cose e mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook con video descrizione
se rischiate di ci vediamo il prossimo
video da ragazzi